salut soir omar haddad alors le 24 juin
1991 madame marchal été retrouvée morte
poignardée barricadé de l'intérieur dans
la cave de sa villa la chamade à mougins
sur la porte on découvre en lettres de
sang l'inscription omar m'a tuer or vous
le jardinier de l'anem marshall vous
appelez justement omar vous êtes
inculpés d'homicide volontaire et
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
partiellement gracié par le président de
la république vous sortirez de prison
après sept ans deux mois et huit jours
derrière les barreaux mais le 20
novembre 2002 la cour de cassation
rejette votre demande en révision votre
procès déclarant que les nouveaux
éléments présentés par votre défense
permettent pas de douter de votre
culpabilité d'autre part
l'avocat de la famille marchal maître
kiejman déclare je ne suis pas étonné qu
omar raddad soient convaincus de n'avoir
pas tué madame marchal tant de gens le
lui répète avec complaisance depuis si
longtemps
soutenir qu omar haddad a été condamné
et le reste parce qu'il est marocain
relève de la pure démagogie dixit maître
kiejman voit la situation omar haddad
gracié mais pas innocenté donc quelque
part toujours coupable alors avec la
collaboration de sylvie lotir on vous
avez écrit un livre qui est publié au
seuil et qui s'appelle pourquoi moi
[Musique]
donc comme un rat date plusieurs livres
ont été publiés sur votre affaire mais
vous vous êtes dit personne ne peut
parler à ma place mieux que moi c'est
vrai pas mieux moi personne passante et
quelque chose ça alors le matin du 25
juin 1991 vous discutez avec latifa
votre épouse et sa soeur sur le balcon
de chez vous à toulon lorsque vous
remarqué sans vraiment y prêter
attention
des gendarmes en bas de l'immeuble
quelques minutes plus tard ont sonné à
la porte il est 11h30 la table du
déjeuner est prête et le type 10s
qu'omar raddad est là et là vous pensez
quoi rien
de ce mariage tard à mourir en raison de
taper à la porte mais bale serait le
vrai la porte qu'on vous dit le tandis
qu'aux hommes sur un marc d'adhérer là
le temps des monos j'ai présenté il m'a
discuter avec nous j'ai dit oui mais
pourquoi
ça reste comme ça pourquoi pourquoi
après me dit non on ne sait pas et je
suis maintenant me
voilà donc au poste les gendarmes vous
dise pourquoi tu as tué madame marchal
vous comprenez pas il vous montre à ce
moment là une photo d'elle couverte de
sang et c'est comme ça en fait que vous
apprenez la mort de madame marchal
commercial après la mort de ma démarche
ensuite vous détourner les yeux ils vous
obligent à regarder une autre photo
celle de la porte de la cave où est
écrit avec du sang omar m'a tuer vous
savez pas bien lire et écrire le
français mais vous reconnaissez omar
parce que ça c'est votre prénom dont
vous savez l'écrire et vous comprenez à
ce moment là évidemment qu'on vous
accuse du meurtre de madame marchal
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre tête à
ce moment là qu'est ce qui se passe
comme ça comme un joueur doué parce que
déjà chez nous au maroc
est ce on est mort on crée pas
on bouge pas on mange pas et chez vous
alors évidemment dans les
interrogatoires qui vont suivre vous
êtes victime d'un gros handicap c'est
que vous connaissez mal le français 1 -
bien que maintenant évidemment ce qui
permettait dites-vous aux gendarmes
d'écrire à peu près ce qu'il voulait
dans l'est dans les procès verbaux et
vous raconter dans votre bouquin que
quand vous parler arabe le gendarme
continue à taper à la machine parce qu'à
cette époque là il ya des questions je
comprends il ya beaucoup de questions je
ne comprends pas c'était populaire est
demandée interprète gendarmerie me
refuse il m'a dit qu'on le connaît
autres perdent et parle bien le français
ça que mon père ça fait 41 morts en
france ouais ça fait commander chacun sa
place non versement pour moi c'est moi
vous fait une confiance aveugle aux
gendarmes un
pour vous les gendarmes ils peuvent pas
mentir donc
cette époque là ouais ouais vraiment
donné oui je n'ai une grande confiance
c'est vrai jamais j'ai pensé à ma caisse
que les passagers renouer
alors durant toutes ces interrogatoires
vous n'avez vous ai pas mais vous dites
que vous finissez par comprendre
pourquoi on peut avouer parce que
finalement on finit par se dénoncer de
crimes qu'on n'a pas commis simplement
pour pouvoir dormir manger et elle est
en paix est là et là vous comprenez ce
qui s'est passé avec patrick dils
financier après après parce que je sais
en a beaucoup des gens posent la
question ne pas traiter ce pourquoi elle
reconnaît un crime n'est pas fait donc
moi je pose pas cette question oui parce
que j'ai passés par là n'importe qu'elle
est capable d'ouvrir n'importe quoi même
des choses était parfaite et capable de
dire où est dessiné tout comme sa tête
de la paix parce que tu es et stéphane
tu es fatigué t'es pas dormir est
capable de
de raconter n'importe quoi comme cette
télé est
à vous est condamnée donc à 18 ans vous
ferez comme je les dix sept en huit mois
et 2 jours
derrière les barreaux et vous dites
quelqu'un qui est enfermé pour rien dans
une cellule de 9 mètres carrés ne compte
pas les jours mais des seconds ouais
ouais parce que c'est là c'est la raison
pour laquelle le titre de mon livre
pourquoi moi ouais parce que c'est
c'est le seule phrase
gdg passe beaucoup dans ma tête et les
dames athlètes pourquoi moi pourquoi
jusque là qu'est ce que j'ai fait ici ça
fait on pose beaucoup beaucoup de
questions et c'est vrai c'est pas on
n'est pas les genres et passe pas si
l'insécurité passe pas cessé
c'est quelque chose intérêts alors
aujourd'hui vous travaillez à marseille
vous prenez le train pour aller tous les
matins marseille à cette heure de toulon
dans une charcuterie halal dans votre
combat maintenant omar haddad et c'est
la raison pour laquelle vous avez écrit
ce livre avec sylvie le tir on vous
voulez que votre innocence soit reconnue
et vous dites si j'étais coupable
croyez vous que je voudrais un autre
procès oui parce qu'elle est quelque
chose moi je comprends pas sonné cause
sans preuve il est désolé on est tous
coupables
qui a tué mais la marche est al omar
haddad quel type de marché sur les
questions et des milliers des personnes
âgées pose cette question
kate et madame marche malheureusement
moi mes avocats la presse ne sont pas
droit d'arrêter le coupable sauf la
justice et notre but est d'arrêter le
combat
quand vous savez dans la phrase de ces
marqueurs omar m'a tuer il ya deux
traces génétiques toutes les zones
différentes on a trouvé dans le south et
marquez ont marre m j'ai précisé quelque
chose parce qu'il y en a sept transilien
s'est pas trouvé n'a pas droit droit de
la porte c'est trop vite ou ses marques
et omar m'a tuer dans le ça ça fait dire
aujourd'hui pour moi je vous sur
certains c'est la personne et l'a écrit
s'est lui-même il a tué madame marche
pourquoi la famille marchal a choisi
pour s'attaquer à un jardinier marocain
sont beaucoup de de pouvoir visons
maître leclerc qui est quand même le
président de la ligue des droits de
l'homme c'est la question que je pose
moi même parce que d'autres départs
c'est vrai rien de voir le personnage
droits de l'homme et après une dernière
fois la ans emilie la justice ouais
de départ ils ont tout fait pour rien a
pas un deuxième procès mais
aujourd'hui je pose la question à tout
le monde surtout à la famille de la
victime
s qui sommes satisfaits la personne est
là tout y est madame marchal comme ça
est-ce qu'ils sont satisfaits pour
s'attarder présent
ça serait pas mis la question
ici un deuxième procès qui prend le
risque
personne ne prend le risque c'est moi
d'y retourner a tourné au wac était
pourquoi lorsque vous avez écopé de 18
ans de prison ce qui est beaucoup mais
ce qui pour un meurtre est moins que la
réclusion à perpétuité
pourquoi la famille de madame marchal
n'a pas protesté c'est la question que
je pose moi même parce que aujourd'hui
le combat
est contre lui pour moi pour ma famille
et aussi pour madame marchal parce qu'il
personne ne mérite de mourir comme ça et
aussi perso les mérites
des 8 ha parce que j'ai des zhu état
parce que c'est grâce aux politiques
publiques c'est grâce à sa majesté
hassan ii et monsieur chirac dion
pourquoi les enquêteurs n'ont ils jamais
interroger votre oncle mimoun qui était
le majordome de madame marcelle pendant
des années parce qu'aimer - dp et
l'après la mort de madame marchal et la
demande est d'avoir le jauge
personnes les côtés après cinq ans et
l'a déclaré qu'est-ce qui est madame
marchal et le dire anémone et la dire à
la presse
hier à côté ça la presse après la
justice il est interrogé un hymne là des
paroles qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à la
presse veut dire à la justice après la
justice et la dct mois trop tard 1 mes
skis la justice et ça bien mieux que le
travail est plus de satin chez madame
marchal ça bien alors pourquoi on pose
pas la question
omar haddad
est-ce que vous avez été victime d'une
machination
oui
est ce que vous savez qui a monté cette
machination
non
[Musique]
savez pas où vous voulez pas le dire
la vérité je sais pas je veux pas causer
je peux pas faire allégeance je peux
accuser quelqu'un sans preuve qu'on m'a
fait moi je moi je le fais pas ça vous
ne rallume bravo
merci
merci beaucoup
pourquoi moi et c'est aux éditions du
seuil
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu